with the recent success of Sonic the
Hedgehog and Netflix's Witcher series we
find ourselves cautiously optimistic for
more adaptations of video games so
here's your quick refresher of some
video game movies and TV shows that are
currently in the works that we're
weirdly excited for provided there are
no further hiccups the big-screen
adaptation of Naughty Dog's blockbuster
action-adventure series is now set to
come out on March 5th 2021 with Tom
Holland starring as a young Nathan Drake
the film was originally set to have Mark
Wahlberg play the wisecracking treasure
hunter but after the film got stuck in
development hell for a while plans had
to shift in fact it was stuck in
development hell for so long
the Marky Mark will now be playing the
role of Sully Nathan Drake's loveable
cigar-smoking father figure and partner
in pillaging horror director Eli Roth
has been tapped to direct the
live-action version of Gearbox's looter
shooter series Borderlands the film is
currently in the early stages of
development with chernobyl writer Craig
Mattson working on the script in a
recent interview Roth expressed his
excitement to be a part of the project
saying I'm so excited to dive into the
world of Borderlands and I could not be
doing it with a better script producing
team and studio outside of the Ubisoft
live-action YouTube shorts that
premiered back in 2016 a movie based on
the post-apocalyptic third-person
shooter is currently set to be released
exclusively on Netflix the division will
star Jessica Chastain and Jake
Gyllenhaal as leads in the film with
rave Judkins from agents of shield
tasked with writing the script and
Deadpool 2 director David lights behind
the wheel coincidentally Judkins is also
gonna be penning the upcoming uncharted
movie back in 2007 halo fans were given
a small taste of what a live action
movie could look like in a show created
by district 9 director Neill Blomkamp
called halo landfall
fast forward 13 years and a nine Episode
television series is currently in
production and if all goes according to
plan it'll be released sometime early in
2021 the Tom Clancy verse is no stranger
to its source material being used in
both video games and Hollywood with the
recent success of the Jack Ryan series
on Amazon it looks like paramount is
also looking to get in on the action by
producing two movies focus
on the character of John Clarke Michael
B Jordan will be playing the character
in two movies one based on the novel of
Rainbow six and the other based on its
origin story without remorse
Stefano's Salima the director behind
Sicario day of the soldato has also been
attached to direct the Resident Evil
movie franchise is proof that success
and longevity can be found in video game
movie adaptations after numerous well
performing movies yes we know they
weren't actually all that good but they
did do very well at the box office
Capcom survival horror franchise is now
shuffling onto Netflix in the form of a
series details are few and far between
currently but the show will reportedly
expand upon the game's lore and deepen
the mythology of the expanded Resident
Evil universe this series is currently
gearing up for pre-production this
spring with actual production following
suit a little later in the year speaking
of Resident Evil Paul WS Anderson the
man behind the movie franchise is
bringing another beloved Capcom property
to the big screen this time it's Monster
Hunter the movie will be led by the
Resident Evil movie franchises leading
lady Milla Jovovich complete with an
ensemble cast made up of Ron Perlman
Tony yaw Megan good and Ti Sony is
currently aiming for an early September
2020 release which hopefully also means
we'll start seeing a steady stream of
trailers for the monster flick in the
very near future Dante the gun slinging
sword wielding silver haired devil
hunter is coming to Netflix The Devil
May Cry Netflix series will be developed
by Adi Shankar executive producer of the
highly successful and very well-received
animated Castlevania series that's also
streaming on Netflix in a recent
interview Shankar revealed that he even
acquired the rights to work on the
series himself so that in his words the
jabronis in Hollywood don't this one up
as well I think it goes without saying
that he plans on playing this animated
series very close to the chest and he's
clearly very passionate about it given
that he and his team knocked the
Castlevania series out of the park
that's pretty encouraging even after
hitting a couple of early production
bumps the Minecraft adaptation is still
set to hit theaters in March of 2022
with Nick and Norah's Infinite Playlist
director peter sollett in charge of the
movie now this isn't the first time
minecraft dipped its blocks into the
narrative space with
he'll tell games creating a very
successful episodic series back in 2017
and while we're not exactly sure how
closely the movies gonna resemble the
game itself we can imagine it's gonna be
very very blocky in terms of plot
details the games developer mo yang said
that it follows the story of a teenage
girl and an unlikely group of
adventurers and they need to save the
beautiful blocky over world after the
malevolent ended dragon tries to destroy
it all produced by Aquaman and fast and
furious 7 director James Wan the Mortal
Kombat reboot is currently in production
in Australia with theatrical release set
for March 2021 with its casting being
officially announced the movie is
looking to be a nice mix of seasoned
actors and fresh faces for one to
destroy with some brutal combat and yes
let's combat with a que aside from that
little is known about the upcoming
Mortal Kombat movie but with a producer
like James Wan involved I think it's
pretty safe to say that this upcoming
version will be nothing short of an
action-packed blockbuster that's right
if you haven't heard already the
mustachioed Italian plumber is leaping
into the big screen once again but this
time he's gonna be appearing in an
animated feature and whether you were
too young to remember or simply just
chose to mentally block out the 1993
movie entirely here's a nice little
reminder of why Mario being animated
this time around is probably a good idea
[Music]
yeah those word goombas these guys we're
supposed to be these guys oh and yeah
this is what Yoshi looked like yikes
this time around however Nintendo will
no doubt do more to make sure their
precious plumber is treated right given
how popular and lucrative the Mario
franchise is now if Sega can make it
work for Sonic surely Nintendo can do
the same for the Mario Bros and there
you have it those are some upcoming
video game adaptations that we're
weirdly excited for are there any games
not in production that you think deserve
the Hollywood treatment let us know in
the comments section down below and for
more on all the games movies and TV
shows we listed make sure to keep your
eyes peeled to GameSpot
you